Today on Smarter Every Day you're gonna
learn about big rockets and big cameras.
Is it going now? Woah!
[Rushing air]
Woohoo! Yeah! Oh!
Hey it's me, Destin. I'm at the U.S. Space
& Rocket Center with my new friend Darren,
Who's got a great big camera.
So I contacted him when I found
out he was doing a road trip,
and I knew a great big camera's
needed to film great big things
and one of the coolest things in
America is the Saturn V rocket.
So Darren agreed.
[Music]
(Darren) I had to do a lot of research
before I could even build this camera.
There are certain things that
you have to know ahead of time,
because you don't want to get to a point
where you've invested time and money
and then suddenly you realize
that you've miscalculated,
you know, the image circle for your lens
and suddenly, you're not covering
the entire piece of film.
So I had to do research on lenses -
If they were big enough;
which ones were big enough.
I like detail,
and I'm getting more detail than I think
you can get with any digital camera, so...
You know, when you got a piece of
film that's 504 square inches,
you get a lot of information
from those photos.
Okay, we're gonna shoot f/90 this time.
(Destin) f/90?
- Yeah. So I'm going to meter one
more time, just to double-check.
And I have 90 2/3 in 8 seconds.
It's roughly... The numbers - the green
numbers - are what I'm looking at.
So 64 is here, but then
we're going two more stops.
You can see how... It's
64 and it keeps going.
So that's 128. That's 90.
Yeah, it was just a lot of calculations.
Knowing how much chemistry
to use to develop a sheet...
a film that large.
Um... and then also being
able to calculate how much
extra coverage I would have
that would give me the...
the movements that I
would use on the camera
I had never had to really think about
you know, things like image
circle and bellows draw.
So there was a little bit of math
that hadn't been used in a while.
I wanted to make every shot count,
and now that I've got a 70 pound camera,
It's more pressure, I suppose.
But it's also more rewards,
bigger rewards, so...
The challenges are always part of the fun.
[Motorcycle engine roaring]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.